this is the insta360x3 and this is the
best camera for Action Sports and I've
been reviewing insta360 cameras for a
very very long time and do you know what
I've never done with an insta360 Camera
Action Sports I mean this was kind of an
action sport right
[Music]
but that my friends is all about to
change because I am going snowboarding
and you're probably like that's great
we're so happy for you I don't know how
to snowboard I've never skied never been
on a snowboard I've done nothing in that
realm of sport I know nothing I have no
gear I have absolute zero knowledge so
I'm hoping in this video you guys can
come with me on a journey to go from
Zero to Hero maybe not even superhero
just like way below superhero I just
want to be able to get out there and not
fall too much
oh that one was that that one hurt oh so
in two weeks we are going to be heading
off to Mammoth to take my first ever
snowboarding lesson I have a lot of work
to do in that time frame thank you so
much insta360 for partnering with me on
this video
[Music]
foreign
we even have a snow bundle every
possible Mount that you could ever
imagine that you would ever need the
snow bundle is sick so the thing that I
love so much about insta360 and why this
is such an incredible camera for Action
Sports because it has some features that
traditional action cameras don't have
even though it has the two lenses you
can shoot in a 4K single lens mode so
you can just film with one of the lenses
so as you can see there are two lenses
here that gives you the 360 effect so
you can do all kinds of cool things you
can also shoot 60 frames per second me
mode and in this mode you hold the
selfie stick out and it keeps you in
frame but the selfie stick is
automatically removed it has active HDR
stabilization and 360 Horizon lock it's
also waterproof so it's perfect for
those winter sports the best part is
editing with insta360 footage whatever
you shoot you can basically go in using
the insta360 studio app and be able to
reframe that footage I can go in and
move it frame by frame and kind of
reshoot all of the stuff that I filmed
you can also do this in the iPhone app
which is really fun and easy to use when
you're on the go from the iPhone app you
just something called shot lab where
they give you all of these really cool
shots and they give you this template
that you can follow and using AI it's
able to edit these together for you
automatically it's so cool
[Music]
so the one thing that I don't need is a
new hobby so I'm going to Mammoth and
I'm going to try snowboarding but I
don't know anything about snowboarding I
don't know anything about skiing I don't
really like the cold and I don't know
what's gonna happen so this place
virtual snow La apparently he's been
here for 20 years but it popped up on
Tick Tock because my algorithm was me
looking for snowboarding stuff so here
we are I thought I should probably do
this before I go out onto an actual
Mountain
[Music]
thank you
do we have this outside in this in the
real life in the snow I'm in trouble
yeah
so like technically I should be able to
stand up on this without any help
without holding on
going that way for some reason
[Music]
just holding it with the carpet off for
a few seconds
from side to side okay
well I didn't try to do that that was
that was unintentional so when you
release these oh that feels good
fall over
[Music]
oh
okay so my first lesson
I learned a lot I now know I could rep
my board and all my gear from here so I
feel like progress has been made oh I
gotta push the button I'll pull it up
there we go okay I think I might need an
eight and a half
one of the main parts missing in my
snowboard escapades is what am I going
to wear so I'm at this place in Los
Angeles it's called Wave Rave and this
was kind of like the place to go to get
your stuff and 686 has this incredible
NASA suit here's the unfortunate reality
it's for boys so let's see there's a
large there's like an extra extra large
boys like I should probably just try I
should probably try
tempted to get it but like I don't want
to be like first time and this is what I
well actually I would want to be that
would be what I would want to do okay I
wouldn't even think about it the only
thing is the little boys don't have hips
it's a little tight right here maybe I
should do the extra large like I'm
definitely contemplating this
oh my God I literally was in that shop
for oh it feels like actually I might
have been there for like five hours no
joke well me too I didn't buy the
astronaut outfit but I still have
another week before I actually head out
so I'm probably gonna come back for it I
got all the things oh I'm so excited
okay uh time to go home eat dinner and
tomorrow I'm actually taking another
virtual snow lesson so I can try out my
new boots that I bought things have
progressed
I've got boots now let's go
oh it's right here
so let's try to break these things in
and we'll see if I can remember how to
do this
I got new socks
my problem with getting into Hobbies is
like I don't go lightly like I go all in
I'm really hoping I enjoy the sport
because I'm almost all in except I don't
have a board yet I'm gonna hold off on
that
[Music]
thank you
this is my first fall
here we go
thanks so much all right that was my
second lesson I'm feeling much more
confident I'm gonna be so ready for that
Hill I've got a couple more lessons
coming up so stay tuned heading in for
technically what is my fifth class the
last class I did was a two-hour
back-to-back session and they recommend
not doing that because one hour on these
machines is like a full day on the
slopes and let me tell you the weirdest
muscles like in my ankles that I didn't
even know that I had were hurting we
have two more sessions three more days
before I head up to the mountain
[Music]
I just made a lot
of last I'm gonna go buy
them I literally have everything else
I'm clearly into it I'm gonna do this
again I'm going to my board right now
back to Waverly
[Music]
well this is incredibly overwhelming
this one has pink on it we like that so
this is gonna be like your easiest most
forgiving ride really hard to catch an
edge and then you get over here you're
getting the more like kind of character
words oh that's fine what that is but if
you're gonna be like you're more
aggressive
the cashier
[Music]
so we're just standing in it
okay when you put it on are you like ow
I think so because I think you look like
this is like where you kind of like want
to be yeah
[Music]
thank you
here it is
I can't believe it this was not in my
plans today like I was gonna rent one
and then here we are last minute
decision
got all hooked up
[Music]
this is lesson number six my friends and
then tomorrow I am off to the mountain
this is so exciting I'm so tired right
now barely functioning but you know the
grind is real The Stoke Never Dies or
something I don't know
hello
[Music]
thank you
so one of the things that I really need
to practice is actually holding my insta
360 camera so I can get some great shots
of hopefully not me falling but I do
feel like that first day I'm gonna be
learning a lot about myself about the
snow
about how bad my body might hurt
[Music]
it's it it's official sixth lesson down
I still feel like there's so much more
that I need to know but I haven't even
touched real snow yet so now we're off
to the mountain
[Music]
I've got so much beer a huge thank you
to 686 for hooking this up I didn't even
know what I needed and they're like we
got you these are all the things you're
gonna need you're gonna be set for the
mountain so let's try it on so some of
these things I bought some of these
things that they sent I'm so overwhelmed
because there's so many goodies I don't
even know where to start we've got some
base layers I'll probably be wearing
long sleeves this is the Athena
insulated jacket it's just everything
I'm already sweating the thing that I'm
most concerned because where am I going
to put my items so the good thing is it
seems like there's lots of pockets in
here they also sent a selection of hats
love nice basic block this NASA hat I
also bought some gloves that have
built-in wrist guards because I'm
concerned about my body
oh wow I'm gonna go do some crime
so this next fit I bought this one at
Wave Rave I was in love with it because
it's like a nice little pale purple so
these are the pants I feel like my next
outfit when I graduate from falling on
my butt all the time I've also got a
matching little jacket
this is this is nice this also matches
my phone you'd love to see it like I'm
only gonna be there for two days but I
have outfits probably for the
eternity of my snowboarding career who
knows maybe I'm gonna be a prodigy maybe
I want to get out there and just be like
[Music]
obsessed with this base layer it's like
a purple leopard we love that and now
the most prized possession the board
does anybody remember when I first
started this entire Adventure I said I
now know I could wrap my board not my
gear from here I'm gonna run all my gear
I'm gonna write my booth send it at my
board and as the day has progressed it
just made sense to get aboard if I'm
gonna start learning and I want to do
the sport like I should be learning on
my own gear so that's what we did got
our helmet I wanted an all
have it in stock so I went with this
like light gray oh my gosh and my
goggles I forgot about those the
plastic's still on these what a loser I
think now that I've done my entire haul
I can officially pack it all up
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so the big days here I've got all my
gear now I'm having a problem because
I've got a lot of things and I'm gonna
be so way down like I feel like a
hamster who is getting ready to
hibernate for the winter like this can't
be safe like having
just sticks in my pocket I'm gonna get
impaled other pocket I'm gonna put 360
camera I've got a little baggie for some
accessories
friends
okay here we are this is gonna be the
start do you want to introduce yourself
howdy I'm Xander you're my instructor
today and I'm so excited I love your
outfit too by the way thank you yeah I'm
a huge camo fan I should have wore mine
I had a white camo one we could have
matched also tomorrow
everything is happening now I'm gonna
put you guys on my helmet and you're
gonna you're gonna witness the first
beginnings of me snowboarding
there we go
[__]
I mean I don't know
no I'm okay okay no we're good
mentally no
I mean I ate it
oh no sorry
[Music]
about how long would you say it took me
to get down that mountain 10 minutes
it felt like five hours
my brain feels a little scrambled from
falling
um I haven't hit my head yet but like
the rest of my body is just all it's
happening though progress is being made
[Music]
what's up
thank you
pulling yourself up
here we go
[Music]
okay one I've ended up with my butt a
lot and I brought some impact shorts but
they really are terrible I bought them
on Amazon and they don't fit very well
they only have extra large is here but
they also have some kids ones so I'm
gonna try out the kids large
[Music]
got some shorts for tomorrow
is
okay you did it we did it we did it yes
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that one was that that one hurt
s
[Music]
so what have we got here this is so cool
so this is an elevated surf craft it's a
snowboard for Surfers yeah it looks
awesome my name's Aaron I'm filming on
Insta 360. we had so much fun oh my gosh
thank you so much for your help my
pleasure thank you
three day two as you saw I bought some
padded shorts and I bought these on
Amazon and I thought they were a little
too aggressive no they're absolutely not
too aggressive and I will be putting
them on today because I took some balls
yesterday and my butt hurts so bad my
arm just even touched it's so painful
but morale is high everyone back out and
I think these shorts hopefully will
protect my body and I definitely should
have worn these day one now I know now
you know
[Music]
it's day three and we're gonna do a
little adjustment here to see if maybe
this might help me out a little bit
let's see what what did you just do push
the heel cup forward and preset to it
too yeah just pulled up most of the way
I pushed it Forward just by listening
nice
I am now holding the stick the first
time
probably gonna have to pass it off to
Xander at some point because I don't
know what's gonna happen but we're gonna
try our best
it feels like I'm going so fast
foreign
[Music]
oh
my God
oh man I'm having so much fun but
fatigue is starting to play a part in
the first two days were pretty intensive
especially for my body it falls
literally feels like I have been in a
car accident this point is the fear
that's holding me back because I'm
afraid of falling because I'm in so much
pain
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
myself
so thank you all for coming along on
this journey this was so much fun and I
can't wait for the next time I feel like
this third day was really tough for me
because my body is so fatigued and I'm
in so much pain doing these last few
runs I knew I had to call it because I
didn't want to get hurt and just
everything just was so exhausted like
even trying to do turns I'm just
starting to get frustrated so I am going
to call it I'm quitting while I'm ahead
I'm not actually quitting just for this
session so I will see you guys on the
slopes again I even downloaded the
slopes app like I've learned so much in
the past three weeks about snowboarding
I am very excited for my new hobby and
can't wait for the next one see you
there
foreign
[Music]